Josh Duhamel and Fergie call it quits
[Music]
after eight years of marriage the couple
has decided to go their separate ways
et can confirm in a joint statement Josh
and Fergie explained quote with absolute
love and respect we decided to separate
as a couple earlier this year to give
our family the best opportunity to
adjust we wanted to keep this a private
matter before sharing it with the public
they added quote we are and will always
be united in our support of each other
and our family the two who share a 4
year old son
axel haven't been seen together in
public recently but looked happy while
celebrating their eighth wedding
anniversary back in January the 44 year
old actor shared this pic on Instagram
with their little one writing eight
years love you babe while the singer
gushed over the milestone with this
sunset shot alongside the caption happy
8th anniversary to my bay eath he caught
up with Josh and make where he opened up
about his relationship with Fergie I
read in her in an interview recently
with something surprising that you don't
consider yourself like like a sex symbol
just for you I mean he probably doesn't
either I think she does she still likes
me she still like she actually is
actually done you know like the
confidence that I need
[Music]